uh
this is gonna be hard hey everyone i'm
abby sharp welcome to abby's
[Music]
kitchen last time on abby sibo saga
[Music]
you're in peeling this never-ending
onion there's just so much to unpack and
none of it is black and white
i'm so frustrated but first let me tell
you at my sponsor element now i know a
lot of folks are thinking about taking
up new exercise regimens and activities
in the new year and one of the biggest
nutrition mistakes my sports rd
colleagues and i see is not properly
rehydrating when extra hydration is
indicated for a lot of people plain
water is just fine but for folks who are
doing longer higher intensity workouts
exercising in the heat or who are just
what we call salty sweaters there's
definitely a role for a well-balanced
electrolyte replacement so when i pulled
my sports rd colleagues a lot of them
told me that element was their personal
go-to product because it has a
science-backed electrolyte ratio of 1000
milligrams of sodium 200 milligrams of
potassium and 68 milligrams of magnesium
it has no added sugar coloring gluten
artificial sweeteners or other
ingredients for folks who are extra
sensitive and it's been the go-to
electrolyte replacement for us olympians
special forces and other professional
athletes i myself am not doing any
strenuous activity right now but i did
use this product occasionally when i was
nursing and pumping because i felt i was
having a hard time keeping up with the
hydration demands and it definitely did
help me feel more human even if i was
like a shell of myself postpartum so if
you want to give element a try you can
get a whole sample pack of eight
different flavors for the price of
shipping that's just five dollars for us
orders so check out the link in my
description to get yours today all right
so i got the doctor to prescribe the
medication i got the dietitian
colleagues to help with the adjunct diet
and supplements i'm going to now tell
you everything i'm doing to kill this
sibo once and for all but very quickly
if you are new sibo stands for small
intestinal bacterial overgrowth which
causes like severe bloating and gas and
distension it's not good but it's not an
infection and it's not all bad bacteria
it's literally just too much bacteria of
any kind in the small intestine now it's
often caused by like a really bad bout
of food poisoning causing nerve damage
that possibly interferes with like the
normal cleaning waves in the gut but in
my case it's theorized that it was maybe
from doing like four back-to-back rounds
of antibiotics that i was doing to treat
mastitis that i got from pumping
exclusively for my son ah motherhood so
fun so glamorous i know so first let's
talk about the medication i'm going to
be taking and
huge disclaimer disclaimer
disclaimer throw it up on the screen
here folks do not i repeat
do not try to replicate this protocol
this is unique to me my numbers my needs
so always speak with a dietitian and a
doctor to come up with a strategy that
works for you
as i mentioned in my previous video i
have been on something called bismuth
style complex for two and a half months
so this is a second generation biofilm
disruptor and a biofilm is kind of like
the little bees nest or like the home of
the bacteria so we want to break that
down to make it easier to kill the
colony inside with the antibiotics
that's number one next we decided on
doing a combination of antibiotics
because we do have evidence that it's
just more effective to combine
medications for sibo compared to just
doing one medication at a time the first
one is called rifaximin which is kind of
the gold standard antibiotic for all
cases of sibo so it has the most
research to support its use and it's
fairly low risk and it's a localized
antibiotic meaning it stays in the gut
and it's poorly absorbed systemically
but if you recall from my first sibo
video i did rifaxmen already and while i
felt
amazing while on the treatment the sibo
came back right away
probably because it's rarely enough to
eradicate methanogenic bacteria all on
its own so the second antibiotic that
we're going to add in this time is
called neomycin and that has research to
suggest it's the most ideal drug to
with rifaximin specifically when you
have methanogenic bacteria to get rid of
now i wasn't able to use neomycin the
last time i treated my sibo because it's
a black box drug and it has a ton of
potentially scary side effects that are
not safe to use while breastfeeding most
notably things like deafness tinnitus
risk of c diff and antibiotic resistance
etc now admittedly when you read things
like that you're like holy no thank you
i was just like is this worth it but of
course i spoke to professionals and we
were weighing out the risk and benefits
i spoke to a number of doctors i
discussed this in my last video and we
determined that considering the low dose
and the very short window that i'd be
taking this that the risk would be
relatively low
now as i mentioned in my last video in
the series the do's and don'ts of the
sibo diet is where things get a little
murky everyone and their grandma has a
different professional opinion
most of which makes sense
physiologically or theoretically but
there isn't a ton of quality research in
this area of practice yet so a lot of
this is really based on like trial and
error or clinical evidence now the diet
suggestion that there's probably the
most consensus on is to focus on meal
spacing so the recommendation is often
three large meals with a solid four to
five hours in between and ideally like a
12 hour fast overnight to help promote
the migratory motor complex so very
quickly the migratory motor complex is
like a big sweeping broom that kind of
moves food along the digestive tract
every 90 to 130 minutes or so so
everything we put anything with calories
into our mouth it halts the migratory
motor complex and it's forced to kind of
reboot and start the process all over
again
reboot and if we aren't allowing this
mmc to occur in full theoretically
bacteria can more easily pool and
flourish it's often theorized that
constantly disrupting the mmc can
potentially contribute to conditions
that cause sibo and yeah like if i'm
honest i'm a mom i am always putting
tiny little bits of things into my mouth
you know whether i'm trying to model
eating broccoli for my kids or like
testing the temperature something for my
baby or tasting a smoothie before i give
it to them to make sure it tastes good
or just like eating scraps off of their
plate this is probably such a common
motherhood experience so i don't feel
bad about this but then it's also
believed that people with sibo have a
deficient mmc due to like nerve damage
in the gut yeah like it's kind of a
chicken egg situation but also grazing
likely exacerbates the sibo problem
anyway for this reason folks with sibo
likely need kind of that longer spacing
between meals to just optimize digestion
and nutrient absorption so for me that
means i'm going to try to aim for
like 8 30 a.m breakfast ish one ish
lunch 5 30ish dinner because that's when
we have dinner as a family 8 30 snack
which i know is not quite four hours but
i need to eat a snack before bed in
order to not wake up in the night hungry
so this is just like the best i can do
especially because i'm just trying to
juggle my kids schedules and my
husband's schedules and activity and
school and meals and all that so i'm not
going to stress over
little details this still has to fit
into my actual real life so i'm doing
the best that i can without going crazy
now unfortunately that's where the
consensus on the sibo diet kind of stops
i would say that almost every other diet
suggestion beyond this is inconsistent
as but they all center around this
concept of limiting the food sources and
the fuel of the bacteria to hopefully
prevent reoccurrence now there are a lot
of different recommended protocols each
with little to no direct evidence to
support their use but the main ones and
their associated sets of rules include
one the specific carbohydrate diet which
largely has you cut out like a variety
of sugars dairy grains and legumes we've
got the gut and psychology syndrome diet
aka gaps diet which eliminates all
grains dairy starchy vegetables and
refined carbs we've got the low fodmap
diet which i actually have done
previously but basically you're to limit
sources of fodmaps based on your unique
triggers to them we've got the sibo
specific food guide which is kind of a
combination of the specific carbohydrate
diet and the low fodmap diet got the
sibo biphasic diet which mainly is about
reducing fermentable starches and fibers
we've got the cedar sinai diet which
focuses mainly on meal timing but also
suggests avoiding sugar alcohols
sucralose and limiting sources of
lactose and fructose the fast track diet
for ibs which gives foods a fermentation
potential based on the glycemic index of
the food and some other nutrition facts
and occasionally we see some people
recommend some form of like the paleo
diet where you're basically avoiding
foods that our ancestors apparently
didn't have access to honestly that
one's total bs now if you feel
overwhelmed know that i do too and what
is even more frustrating is that there
is not a single published paper on the
benefits of any of these diets for
treating sibo none nada now that's not
to say that these diets won't or don't
help with sibo i mean a lot of them
probably do at least help with symptom
management by reducing the fermentable
foods aka the fuel for the bacteria but
we don't have actual trials to prove it
which you guys know i don't love i
actually don't love restricting my diet
period and because i personally feel so
overwhelmed by all the conflicting
recommendations i'm probably just going
to take a more intuitive approach and
change what like i feel like it can
change without causing myself too much
stress so for me i think that's going to
mean one i'm going to probably try to
avoid things with like splenda aka
sucralose in it since splenda is not
like a food i love it's not a food that
i feed my family it's only in some
supplements which i can easily swap out
so i'm gonna switch out my protein
powder which currently contains some
splenda for something that's stevia
based since it does seem like one thing
most of these diets agree on is that
stevia is the most
sibo-friendly sweetener splenda seems to
be like one of the more problematic ones
and then other sugars like maple syrup
and honey are questionable depending on
which diet list you review so this to me
is a pretty easy swap i'm not giving up
anything that i love second i'm also
going to continue to limit some of those
triggering fodmaps as i've really
already been doing because this is just
what feels best to my body anyway and it
may theoretically also help with the
sibo so for me that means limited
lactose limited cruciferous vegetables
limited legumes and very limited sugar
alcohols i'm not going to obsess over it
like i'm not reading every single label
incessantly and if i go out i'm probably
gonna eat those things not gonna lie but
i'm going to focus my meal planning on
other foods that i really like and then
finally i'm largely going to focus my
energy on what i can add not take away
i'm gonna try to have two kiwis daily
which actually has evidence to support
its use for bloating and ibs like
symptoms and i also love kiwis and then
i'm going to focus mainly on the
supplements that i'm going to
add to my life now without evidence i
wouldn't even know which one of these
diets to adhere to so there's really no
point in my mind of me like arbitrarily
following any of them to a t and then
making myself miserable doing so in the
process this has to be
realistic and sustainable okay and
speaking of
there's a lot i'm not gonna lie but
here's where i'm netting out based on
the suggestions from my two dietitian
colleagues and no i am not sponsored by
any of these or married to any of these
brands actually in a lot of cases it was
very hard for me to get anything like
these here in canada like the states
have a lot more options so i certainly
didn't have the luxury to be comparing
options or comparing brands it just i
got what i got so here is
my supplement bin and that's a lot i
also had to create
like a little schedule for myself
because otherwise it was just going to
be like too much work throughout the day
to just like combine oh my god these
ones are okay and then i'm putting them
into these little cute containers to
just simplify my life so that it doesn't
take up my whole day just trying to find
the right supplement in the bin it is a
total mass but so is the rest of my life
so here we are all right let's try to
find what i want to find here okay so
very quickly got the biofilm disruptor
bismuth bile complex which i mentioned
i'm taking for a few months before even
starting the antibiotic treatment this
helps to penetrate the biofilm and make
it easier to target the bacteria living
inside this is sun fiber this is
partially hydrolyzed guar gum really
great for basically digestion for moving
things along for motility constipation
so important when it comes to managing
sibo symptoms and if you can't handle
psyllium because i love psyllium fiber
too but if it's too
gummy for you i find that partially
hydrolyzed guar gum or sun fiber is a
lot clearer less gritty less kind of
gelatinous it's a good option next we've
got bovine colostrum i know that's gross
as a breastfeeding mama
nope but the thinking is that the
immunoglobulins in colostrum may help to
strengthen the mucosal integrity against
bacteria relevant in sibo so that's why
i'm taking that one i've also got this
full spectrum binder it's called gi
detox which is a gross name as you know
but basically the binder helps to pull
out the die off remnants from the
bacterial overgrowth once you're going
through the antibiotic protocol so here
we've got ali max pro this is an herbal
antimicrobial which basically acts as an
adjunct to the antibiotics in killing
off bacteria it does
taste like garlic and i dislike it
greatly but anyways i took it last time
too so this is
back in rotation okay here we've got ox
bile which i know also grow sounding but
basically low bile flow is one of the
purported causes of sibo since bile is
antimicrobial and helps to emulsify fats
so adding bile to the diet theoretically
may help support this process but again
like everything else
we don't actually have actual evidence
of that next we've got digestive enzymes
and i want a flag here that if you have
a healthy working gut you do not need
digestive enzymes hard stop do not let
an influencer say that you do it's just
that the excess bacteria in sibo often
damages the digestive enzymes making it
harder for you to break down food so
again theoretically it may make sense to
add back digestive enzymes but we don't
actually have evidence to support that
so again not something i'm recommending
to the masses this is iberogast
love iberogast so basically it's an
herbal tincture of peppermint chamomile
licorice root lemon balm and a few
others but we actually have evidence to
support its use for ibs and functional
dyspepsia so yeah i personally find this
one to be quite helpful for me to have
with meals especially during the whole
sibo healing journey okay so we've got s
boulardii probiotic so the question of
whether or not to take a probiotic
supplement is debatable in sibo groups
but most experts agree that if you're
going to take a probiotic saccharomyces
boulardii espolardi is one of your best
bets so this has been studied with
antibiotics in the treatment of sibo and
it's had really favorable results both
with and on its own even without the
antibiotics it also appears to enhance
nutrient absorption and it isn't
affected by antibiotics so it is safe to
take during the treatment so we love
that okay another probiotic i'm taking
is called orthospore so you will often
see people talk about spore based
bacillus coagulant strains of probiotics
which are often seen as again one of the
best probiotics for sibo now we
definitely need more research in this
area but one small study did find a
significant decrease in sibo symptoms
and positive sibo tests yeah adding that
to the mix may help to kind of like
re-inoculate the gut once we're wiping
everything out with the drugs okay then
we've got magnesium citrate aka
magnesium calm so this is a really
common over-the-counter supplement for
constipation that really helps to draw
water into the intestines to stimulate
the bowels so when treating sibo
especially methanogenic bacteria we
really need to focus on working those
bowels so any little additions like
magnesium citrate can definitely help
especially because that neomycin can do
some wonky things to digestion and
motility so yes adding this to the
rotation can definitely help okay and
then i've got peppermint capsules this
one is really as like an as needed basis
so it does have research to support its
use for ibs especially things like
bloating and digestion gas for those
days when i'm really feeling the effects
of those antibiotics
these may come in handy for me also
ginger finally again i'm mainly going to
be taking this on like an as needed
basis to just help manage any nausea
symptoms that i might get from the drugs
but ginger also has some pro kinetic
properties some research has actually
shown that it can help with motility and
i actually took ginger supplements after
antibiotic treatment in my last go so i
am going to keep this in rotation this
time as well that is what i'm going to
be focusing on i mean there are so
many options recommended for sibo like
it's it is not like this is an
exhaustive list believe it or not or a
one size fits all model and i don't even
know for sure that any or all of these
things are going to help everyone's
needs are going to be so different so
please speak to a registered dietitian
do not even attempt to copy this without
speaking to a healthcare provider i
cannot even attest to whether or not all
of these things or any of these things
are going to necessarily help but i'm
leaning on the experts here i'm leaning
on my colleagues who see sibo patients
day in day out help guide me to make the
best decisions here and really i'm just
trying to give this my absolute best
shot because yeah this might be
the last and only time i'm able to do
the neomycin pharmaceutical drugs now
finally there are a few additional
lifestyle suggestions that i want to
incorporate into my life that may help
to support my treatment but also just be
kind of good for me in life in general
so one of those is to engage in
activities to stimulate the vagus nerve
which is one of the main components of
the parasympathetic nervous system which
oversees pretty much everything from
your digestion to your mood to your
immune response via the brain gut access
so we do have evidence that vagus nerve
stimulation can serve as a promising
add-on treatment for ibs and you don't
have to pay for any kind of like fancy
therapy to stimulate it so singing
humming laughing deep breathing and
gargling with water a few times a day
are all effective strategies for
stimulating the vagus nerve that is all
stuff that i can incorporate into my
routine easily enough especially since i
sing pretty much everything i say as a
mom so this is really business as usual
as far as i'm concerned and then of
course there's also trying to get in
some gentle movement trying to manage
sleep and stress which probably i don't
know deserves like a whole other video
to unpack but i will just say that i
have started new medication for my sleep
which is definitely helping me sort
through that but again that's like a
whole other video so i'll get to that
another time but this is just my plan
it's a lot i know the key word mine ma
not yours not yours not yours not yours
not yours and for the freaking millionth
time do not attempt to
copy this without individualized care
from a registered dietitian that
specializes in digestive support so
again i'm leaving some links to my
colleagues below investing in all of
this without a whole lot of research to
support it is again not how i like to
roll this is not my style it's not what
i recommend but ultimately we gotta work
with what we got here and i really don't
have a whole lot of options so i
personally have had to weigh out the
risks and the benefits of engaging in a
protocol like this and for me me
personally this is just where i'm
netting out so whether you're struggling
with sibo or weight loss or cancer or
some other kind of chronic condition you
need to work with a team that you trust
that is evidence-based to the best of
their ability to be able to weigh out
the potential risks and benefits for you
no youtuber no influencer not even a
professional like me can make a call
that's going to apply to the masses so
if you want to see how this all shakes
out for me stay tuned for part four of
my sibo saga but until then leave me a
comment below if you've got any
questions that you want me to answer
subscribe to the channel and i will see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]